the North remembers we know no king but
the King in the north whose name is
stark I don't care he's a bastard
that starts blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day you're a war not just wolves
sometimes in my dreams a three-eyed
Raven you seen it together
it was walking no the Raven is something
different something deeper the Raven
brings the sight what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight and Game
Theory's video today I want to talk
about Jojen Reed and his green dreams
back in season 4 episode 5 there was a
scene that featured Joe Jenn Mira Hodor
and Brian Stark and in this scene Jojen
may have foreshadowed something
significant about the end of Game of
Thrones this character may not have had
a large role in the show but he had a
very important one to say the least
Jojen Reed has a form of greensight he
had the power of prophetic green dreams
a person with green sights sometimes
dreams as other people but the green
dreams are different they are filled
with symbolic meaning images and
metaphors of what is to come the meaning
behind the dreams is not always obvious
but the dreamer experiences the
fulfillment of visions in the unfolding
of events supposedly these dreams can
concern the dreamer or another person
but the dreamer will always be able to
tell the difference
Green seers might also dream of their
own deaths in the Song of Ice and Fire
novels greensight seems to be limited to
people who are blood of the first men
like the free folk and the Northmen
including the chronic men this may have
some connection with the fact that the
first men lived in Westeros for
centuries alongside the magical children
of the forest and they even adopted
their religion of the old gods in the
television show we know that brain stark
and Jojen Reed both possess the power of
green
dreams before bran even meets Jojen Reed
in person he comes to him during one of
his dreams and shortly after this is
when they meet for the first time
Jojen was sent to bran via the
three-eyed Raven who was sending him
dreams and jochen's main purpose is to
help get brand to the three-eyed Ravens
cave brain knows that he has some sort
of power and Jojen tries to help bran
open his third eye they talk about how a
brain Stark experienced a prophetic
dream that his father was in the crypts
of Winterfell when Eddard Stark was
indeed executed in King's Landing
Bran's younger brother Rickon also
experienced a similar dream in Jojen
Reed later explained to bran that this
was a green dream and that he had a
similar dream the day Eddard was killed
it's interesting that they share some of
the same green dreams but Joe John was
also seeing things that bran would not
see Jochem was constantly being sent
dreams of future events in fact Jojen
had seen his own death before he even
met brain stark this is something we
learn when bran meets the three-eyed
Raven my brother he let us see you and
now he knew what would happen from the
moment he left he knew and he went
anyway how do you know I've been
watching you all of you
of your lives Jochen knew he would die
by the time bran made it inside the cave
but he went along and helped him anyway
because he knew how important bran would
become Jojen once told Bryan you are the
only thing that matters and he would
stop at nothing in order to get him to
the three-eyed raven but what I want to
talk about is what happened before they
made it to the cave
Jojen once said something to brain and
Mira that could have foreshadowed the
end of the series but keep in mind this
is full of tinfoil so just bear with me
the scene I want to talk about was when
Jojen Mira Hodor and bran were captured
I crashed her ski at the time
Craster and Lord Commander Mormont were
already dead Karl Tanner actually had
control of Craster's keep and he was
keeping Jojen Mira Hodor and Brian tied
up during another scenic raster's key we
get some more evidence that Jojen Reed
doesn't FAC see future events in his
dreams
in this scene coral is preparing to
torture and most likely rape Meera Reed
and Jojen tells Karl what is about to
happen to him later that night and this
is what he says
[Music]
so you died tonight I saw your body burn
I saw the snow fall and bury your bones
as you can see Jochen had already seen
these events play out in his dreams he
knew Karl Tanner would die before the
night was over it seems like Jojen sees
several characters deaths before they
actually happened he dreamed of Ned
Stark in the crypts of Winterfell before
he died he saw Carl Tanner's death
before it happened
anny saw his own death before it
happened but is it possible that Jojen
may have seen the fate of brain stark as
well the next scene I want to show you
could be very important because it may
foreshadow a few different things
depending on how you want to interpret
it before they were able to escape
Craster's keep
Jochen tells a brand that no matter what
happens he needs to make it out alive
he tells brain that this isn't going to
be the end for him but then Jojen has a
very odd local in his face he is telling
brain that this isn't the end for brand
but as he looks away from him he says
not yet this has always made me wonder
if Jojen had seen brains death in a
dream but he chose not to tell him
before this scene ends Meera says how
will we know the end before Jojen
answers her he looks at his hand as it
is on fire and then he says you will
know this is also very interesting
because it can mean a few different
things take a look at the scene for
yourself then I will throw a few ideas
out there you have to make it
we will
this this isn't the end
Oh for you
I had
how will we know the end
no no okay now one way to look at this
is you could say Jojen is referring to
his own death
we know Jojen knew he was going to die
but Jojen does not die by fire because
Mira slits his throat to put him out of
his misery
but jochen's body is basically exploded
by the children's fireball grenade so
perhaps that is what his burning hand is
symbolizing that would probably be the
safest way to explain what Jojen meant
by this but I'm not so sure about that
because in the scene Jojen is talking
about the end for bran
he says bran needs to survive and then
he says this won't be the end for bran
but then he says not yet that entire
scene was very ominous which makes me
think he could be referring to brains
death when he says it's not the end for
him yet whatever he is referring to will
have something to do with fire since he
was looking at his hand on fire as he
said you will know the end we all know
there will be a lot of fire involved in
how Game of Thrones ends Daenerys
Targaryen has dragons and the night King
has a dragon so we can expect to see a
lot of things burned the next season
including people now what I also find
interesting about jochen's burning hand
is it reminds me of what happened to Jon
back in the first season when we see him
kill the white in Lord Commander Mormont
chambers
so
when Jon Snow grabs the lantern he burns
his right hand and that's the same hand
Jojen is looking at that's on fire
I wonder if this scene will have any
connection to Jon Snow
because Jon is obviously very close to
bran and Jojen says he will know the end
jochen's whole purpose was to get Brian
to the three-eyed Raven
then when brain gets there the visions
of the three-eyed Raven decides to show
bran has to do with John's birth so
obviously he will play a big part in the
endgame the three-eyed Raven could have
shown brand anything but he chose to
show him things that have to do with
John so maybe jochen's hand burning is
also another reference to Jon being
needed to end the war against of the
night King not only did John's hand burn
when he grabbed the lantern but if John
ends up wielding a flaming sword it will
look like his entire arm is on fire as
he is carrying it now I know some people
don't think John fits the Azur Ahai
prophecy which could be true but
whenever Melisandre looks into her
flames for a glimpse of azor Ahai the
only thing where lore shows her is snow
the snow also has a capital S as if
George is spelling someone's name like
John's what Jojen said - brain also kind
of reminds me of what benjin said to
bran back in season 6
after benjin saved brain Amira he tells
brand that he needs to be ready for when
the night King comes was good too
controlling for the night King comes
drink
one way another it will find his way to
the will of men when he does you will be
there waiting for him and he will be
ready as you can see benjin said one way
or another the night King will make his
way south and when he does bran will be
waiting for him and he will be ready
this sounds very similar to what Jojen
said because Jochen said brain would
know the end but what does it mean how
will he know the end and does it have
anything to do with Jojen looking at his
hand burning when he says you will know
i know that the simple answer is Joe
John was referring to himself but it
would be way more interesting if that
conversation was foreshadowing the end
game of the entire series I like to
imagine the fire is metaphorical or
symbolic just like when this sea was
crashing over Winterfell walls and Jojen
saw the snow overcoming Carl Tanner the
fiery hand could symbolize death by
dragons or even Melisandre not only does
Melisandre sacrifice people by using
fire but Melisandre is currently heading
to volantis and many of us believe she's
going there to retrieve the fiery hand
the fiery hand contains a thousand
soldiers never more and never less each
of these soldiers is a slave of her Lord
I am kinda hoping Melisandre brings them
to Westeros so they can add to the great
war ending in a nice verse fire battle
fire soldiers versi soldiers and fire
dragons verse ice dragons it could make
for one hell of an ending if brain stark
is going to be ready for the end like
Jojen and benjin told him then I assumed
this is something he will learn inside
of the weirwood net perhaps brain and
the night king meet inside of the
weirwood net once again but this time
brain does something to the night king
instead of the night king grabbing bran
the night king scared the [ __ ] out of
brand when he grabbed his arm then he
scared him again when brain was watching
him with the Ravens beyond the wall I
don't think the night king will scare
him for a third time eventually bran
will be able to fully harness his powers
and this is when the night king needs to
be defeated for
good or bran may have another vision
that involves John snow in some way I am
assuming it will have something to do
with John since brands biggest
revelations inside of the weirwood net
always include John in some way whether
it's John snows birth or his parents
getting married either way it shows John
snows importance and in order for John
to be the night king he may have to
embrace who he truly is John needs to
activate his own powers by embracing his
I side and his fireside what do all of
you think
do you believe Joe Jim was simply
referring to himself during that scene
or was he hinting at something far more
important than just himself let me know
what do you think his burning hand
represented put all your thoughts down
below in the comment section I want to
thank you all very much for stopping by
and watching the video and I also want
to thank all of you on patreon for
continuing to support my channel I
really appreciate that have a great day
everyone I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you